Speaker 1: All right, we are going to
take a tour today. It's not going to be
a fun tour. I'm not going to lie. This is not
exactly touring UNESCO's World Heritage sites and
amazing architecture and sights and views
and these different things landscapes.
This is going to be a tour through madness, quite
frankly. The world is increasingly horrified by
the anti-vaccine madness happening across the
United States in media, at school board meetings,
at rallies and at other places. Now, many of you
would rightly point out there have been anti-vax
elements in many countries around the world,
and you would be right. But the combination of
the United States being one of the countries that
first had access to as many vaccines as we could
possibly want, and being one of the largest and
most powerful countries in the world, combined
with the degree of wide ranging anti-vaccine wrist
insanity is getting a lot of negative attention
for us. It's humiliating. It's embarrassing that
this is what the United States is being known
for. So let's start the tour. First, there was
an anti-vaccine mandate march in New York City,
and this were just these are anecdotes we're
just dropping in. Here's one guy who says
that the mandates are Orwellian and like Nazi
Germany, which is Remember we did our story last
week. Anti-Vaxxer ism and COVID conspiracies push
people towards anti-Semitism. One element of that
is the trivialization of the Holocaust, because
vaccine requirements that you can test out of
or like if you want to work here, you should go
and get a vaccine. Otherwise you're going to have
to test or leave. That's not what the Nazis were
doing to the Jews. OK, very, very different.
Speaker 3: It's tough to say we do not comply.
So what's going on with these mandates? You know,
this stuff is Orwellian. It's it's
totally Nazi Germany type stuff. And so,
you know, we're just done with it, right?
Speaker 1: It is not Orwellian and it is not Nazi
Germany type stuff. It's just it is not the same
guy was again, we don't know who this guy is, just
just a rant. Doesn't matter is the point. This
is a guy, random anti-vaccine activist who's been
infected with this stuff. Of course, connected all
of it to the Democratic Party and said, This is
all about what the Dems want. Make you weak. Make
you dependent. Destroy the country. This is a wide
spread narrative. Among the right. Take a look
Speaker 3: at the Democrat platform is founded
on this garbage is founded on destruction. Is
founded on making us weak, making us dependent,
making us, you know, just destroying our country.
Speaker 1: Right. So the destruction of the
country narrative make you weak, make you
dependent on the government likening to
Nazi Germany, which is the trivialization of
the Holocaust. It's checking all the boxes
and most of the world, and more than half
of the United States sees this and says,
Do these people not realize how humiliating
and embarrassing this is? This is absolutely
wild. Then just going to something totally
different. Here's Naomi Wolf. Naomi Wolf is
off the deep end. I don't know how many of you are
familiar with Naomi Wolf. When I was in college,
there would be many classes where we would
see clips of neo communications courses. We
would see clips of Naomi Wolf making interesting
critiques and analysis. She seems completely off
the deep end, and she says the only people ever
subjected to mandatory vaccinations were slaves.
What, Naomi? Yeah, that's what she says.
Speaker 4: Coercing people to have a vaccination.
We've never had that in the United States in our
entire history unless you were an enslaved person.
Speaker 1: Now, that's not true. I have no
idea where Naomi Wolf gets that idea. But
right now, all 50 states plus D.C.
mandate immunization for a number of
conditions to go to public schools. Diphtheria,
tetanus, pertussis, polio, measles. You know,
there's a long history of vaccine requirements.
I just some of these things are so stupid
that you don't even really know what they
mean because it's so obviously untrue.
But now Naomi Wolf is being held up as some
kind of oracle by some on the right people,
who, by the way, would never listen to Naomi Wolf
ever, ever, ever before. A very, very strange.
Then we go to a California high school teacher.
This is now going to the school board part. So
we've done rally anti-vax back rally. We then did
right wing. Idea that was like the war room or,
you know, one of those Real America's voice, the
things Steve Bannon's on and we heard from Naomi
Wolf. Now we're going to school board. Here
is a California high school teacher who says
he will fight the mandate no matter what it
what happens. He might lose his job because
he answers to God and his wife. Now, his wife
may be anti-vax. I have no reason to believe
that if God exists, God is anti-vax. I'm still not
really aware of any religion that's just flat out
no vaccines. Let's take a listen to this guy.
Speaker 2: I'm willing to fight this mandate
for my family and my community if it means I
lose my job. I'll be able to sleep at night
knowing I stood up for freedom, and I'm
certain that history will say that I'm
on the right side of science as well. I only
answer to God my wife, not the government.
Speaker 1: And look at the cheering
and the fist pumping and the USA chant.
It's actually hard to think of anything more
anti-American than what that guy is doing,
I mean, truly, truly. Now we will go from
a school board meeting room. It's a tour
through the insanity. We're now going to
the floor of the House of Representatives.
Here is congressman, along with
some very strange comparison between
the military requiring vaccines, and
I think he's talking about new coke.
Take a listen. See if you can figure it out.
Speaker 2: 1886 The product was brought online
Coca Cola and remained one of the most popular
products of all time until 1985, 99 years later,
and they came out with a great idea. New Coke
Right problem is new Coke was a terrible.
Speaker 1: That's the problem idea.
Speaker 2: And three months later,
they brought back what they call classic
coke. Because of this terrible, terrible
idea that had to be fixed. Making our military
be vaccinated against their will is a terrible,
terrible idea that needs to be fixed.
Speaker 1: Now, the funny thing is,
it's not a new idea. There have been vaccination
requirements in the military for a really,
I don't even know how long for a really long
time. They're just adding the COVID 19 vaccine
as happens when new vaccines are developed. They
get added as requirements for the military. The
really funny thing is, it's nothing like new coke,
actually. I don't want to go on a whole tangent
in business school. We did a case study on New
Coke. New Coke is a really interesting business
case study, actually. There was also another one,
I think like Pepsi Clear, it tasted like Pepsi,
but it looked it was transparent. And
I think that also failed in any case.
Very interesting business discussion about
the history of New Coke. The analogy to a
vaccine requirement for the military simply not
there, then. Oh, this is really interesting.
So then on Fox News, they talk about a clip
of CDC Director Rochelle Walensky saying,
We need to educate people about the vaccines
so they become comfortable going and getting
it. They need to learn about the vaccine. And
Fox News acts as if what she's talking is about
reeducation, alluding to reeducation
camps and dictatorships. But Rochelle
Walensky didn't say it. Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Mayor de Blasio has warned city
workers if they don't get the vaccine
by Friday, they will be put on unpaid
leave. And now the CDC is planning to quote
educate those who are hesitant to get the
shot. Here's CDC Director Rochelle Walensky.
Speaker 2: We believe it is very important
Speaker 5: to get these people vaccinated. There
is a plan should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and counseling to get
people the information they need so that they are
feeling comfortable and getting vaccinated
Speaker 4: did something about
that phrase reeducation?
Speaker 1: She didn't say
reeducation. You notice what they did there. She
didn't say reeducation, she said. We've got to
educate people about the science of the vaccine
Speaker 4: and get these people on board. It seems
pretty strikingly similar to a really
tragic chapter in our Globes history.
Speaker 1: I guess I don't know what
I don't know if she's talking about
slavery or the Holocaust. It's not
even clear what she's referring to,
but it's crazy. And then they build on this. They
just continue building, building, building on it,
even though it was it. Rochelle Walensky
said, We've got to educate and the host as
reeducation. Whoa, and they just keep going.
Speaker 4: Harris part of what is so troubling is
the notion of that. Again,
the reprograming in education,
Speaker 1: where she never said
reprograming that I mean, they're
they they came up with that out of thin air.
Speaker 4: You are automatically branded an enemy.
You are automatically branded, frankly, a criminal
in some sectors, if you dare to even question if
you dare to to expect what we were promised.
Speaker 1: So you get it. They introduced
the term reeducation, which Rochelle Walensky
didn't. And here is Tommy Tomi Lahren saying
she's so proud of people standing up against this.
Speaker 4: But I also like to say this when we
see this protest in Brooklyn and we see these
workers standing up. When I saw those images,
nothing made me feel more proud to be an American
because I saw Americans of every color, every
shape, every size, every gender and probably every
political affiliation standing together in the
name of freedom. That's American as it gets. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So you guys get the idea an absolute
humiliation globally for the United States, it's
everywhere. It's on right wing media. It's on
the floor of the House. It's at rallies. It's
everywhere. And I don't think it's going away
anytime soon. Let's now talk about something
opposite this when it comes to vaccines